à propos des attentats et les suites des
attentats enfin la question que tous les
new-yorkais se pose et dont on reparlera
demain le conseil municipal fautive
reconstruire le world trade center oui
et encore plus haut avait indiqué la
mairie dans un premier temps mais les
avis sont partagés
daniel boys 3 l'amérique est un pays où
tout va si vite
des milliers de corps sont encore sous
les décombres et déjà la question de la
reconstruction du world trade center se
pose
le seul monument possible à cet endroit
près d'un mémorial
j'aimerais revoir les twin towers à leur
place c'est même plus autant qu'avant
l'histoire de leur montrer qu'on n'a pas
peur et qu'il ne nous auront pas new
york ce sens force et on va reconstruire
encore mieux qu'avant parce que ce
serait bien faire un immeuble pour
recommencer les affaires et montrer les
valeurs de l'amérique
faire un symbole du capitalisme et de la
liberté maison de badine pas avec un
lieu stratégique le coeur du quartier
des affaires à new york un ensemble
immobilier qui représentait à lui seul
un bureau sur 10 à manhattan
la moitié de la défense à paris pour le
maire de new york
la question ne fait aucun doute et pour
le gouverneur de l'état non plus une
semaine après les attentats il freine
déjà date pour l'avenir
allons reconstruire tout ça et pas
seulement comme c'était avant mais plus
solide encore l'écrivain paul auster
chantre d'un new york cosmopolite
fenêtre sur le monde imagine à l'opposé
un projet symbolique en souvenir de la
tragédie
je préfèrerais avoir une morale là et
peut-être avec un les détours en
minuscules et et un terrain vide mais
qui sait jean paul didier lui et
spécialiste de la construction des tours
il vient d'en livrer deux pour le
quartier de la défense
je crois que si on voulait vraiment
prendre une décision qui montre le
courage tout montre que l'on a du
courage tout montre que l'on a encore
confiance en l'avenir
on construira s'étendre là des tours
mais pas les mêmes des tours plus grande
des tous plus modernes détour d'une
autre type les fondations des tours sont
sérieusement ébranlé comme par un petit
tremblement de terre et le site n'est
qu'à un mètre seulement au dessus du
niveau de la mer il faudra tout étayé et
renforcé en tout état de cause la
silhouette de new york ne sera plus
jamais comme avant